hi I have a bit of a problem for some
reason and I don't know why my camera
has decided to get stuck all the way
zoomed in and I mean all the way and no
matter what I do no matter what I press
on it it doesn't change I've turned it
off I've removed the batteries I don't
want to do a factory reset and that will
probably fix it but I'm not gonna do
that just because it technically works
so I don't want to break it just in case
it decides to not work so I don't know
what I'm gonna do but you know literally
speaking this is supposed to be a face
cam and I know that a lot of edits are
supposed to be like zooms of faces for
haha funniness but I guess we're just
gonna have that all the time it's kind
of some Blair Witch thing going on right
now which isn't a bad thing considering
I'm about to play a horror game but it
is just a little odd and I just wanted
to address that because I didn't want to
open up this video and be like hey guys
nothing's weird about this one what are
you talking about are you crazy yet no
I'm aware I know um yeah I know I just
wanted to get it out of the way first
and foremost and I don't think it'll be
too much of a problem so let's play SCP
containment breach
hi it's gonna be up close and personal
it's okay just look longingly into my
eyes and it'll get normal sooner or
later just keep looking
this is gonna seem like some stranger
things [ __ ] but it's also very hot
so I'm very sweaty I haven't been
mindful aid I'm just me I'm hot so I'm
gonna chug this water to keep my body
temperature down so that nothing dies
inside of me okay all right it's all
just a little just a little too low so
we can just like some goddamn interview
with the person in like protected
custody or like the protect the
protected witness the witness protection
[Music]
there's been a like a four-minute no way
it's been way cut down from that but
there's been like a to long avert let's
play the game it has been a while since
I played this there's been a number of
updates to the game and if you remember
last time it was a little bit unstable
so with this one I'm trying to play a
build that is not one of the most recent
builds for the experimental weekly
builds I think this is a stable build
unless something goes horribly wrong and
if something does I will go back and try
to find a more stable build so with that
being said here we go back into the
world of SCP containment breach it's
going to be zoomed in but it's gonna be
i've room it lick see and i'm sorry i've
removed like 90% of your jokes
you can't zoom in what are you gonna do
zoom in on an eyeball that's not funny
that's not funny at all what are you
gonna zoom in on a tooth my blue tongue
which is perfectly normal and natural so
I don't know what new they've added but
I'm guessing it's still gonna start oh
yeah in the same place that the other
ones started which is very cool did I
have a hand last time I can't remember I
think I did did I maybe I didn't
man I got some meaty fingers I bet I
could do some damage with those fingers
hey this looks this looks roughly the
same if I do recall hey don't mind as I
stand on your corpse was there anything
upstairs that I needed to grab I'm
hoping that this build is going to be
more stable yeah yeah yeah okay okay
whatever we're moving on what the hell
no it's probably nothing there was
nothing there right I thought I saw
something okay all right here I go
where's my blinker doing out of a blink
o meter why don't I have a blink ometer
where's my blink on why am I not
blinking where's my blink oh you know if
enough people like this zoom didn't look
because I know how much you appreciate
my pores maybe I'll do it all the time
then is it's a good look it's a good
it's not a good it's not great look but
it's a it's a look okay here we go
now we're really in the thick of it okay
so there's got to be way to this already
looks new I don't remember there being a
down here I don't have a flashlight or
anything so I don't know if I'm gonna
need this
okay all right a little bit odd but I
like that I like areas that just exists
it's better if the world isn't just
boxes and hallways that you can go in
and nothing you can't because that
doesn't make sense what is this lost
your PDA me - can someone seal this
please and me seal what
service ducts ventilation ducts alright
okay for the symbol was that a face on
the wall oh no I'm just crazy seeing
faces big of meaty faces oh oh oh wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait what are
you doing here what are you doing here
why are you doing did you freeze oh no
you're just very still um all right hey
I got our Barbie spike it's one of those
boss town dynamics thingamabob errs okay
just gonna skidooed Lee doodle over here
hey can I go in the vent that it came
out of though I'm gonna save I don't
like that that's some cool lighting Oh
No thank you no thank you on that one
I'll take a big heaping have to give my
arm all the way up here so you know what
I'm doing and I'm not just scratching
something unsettling Oh God dead bodies
my favorite you know a lot of this
actually looks very different can I get
down there I can't jump my legs don't
work but that's what I'm talking about
uh you know in regards to world building
like things that exist outside of simply
the hallways of which I am walking
through that makes things feel a lot
more real I am a little concerned
because of how different things have
been so far that I think you're gonna
throw a curve by old
okay there's those robos but this is all
closed off all right oh that was here I
see well I still don't have a need to
blink
oh it's I've been through that before
well I need to blink my eye suddenly
have a pain in them thought I had more
time okay right
weighing 468 kilograms 468 it moves so
fast for something so rotund man loading
takes a long time oh good I'm here why
am i year oh my gosh scrub-a-dub-dub rub
it in my tub I feel I feel like I should
have fixed the camera but at this point
we're all in this to deep to go out of
it anymore I'm hoping that you're all
holding your computers and or laptops
and or tablets and/or phones as close to
your face as possible so that we can all
share in this experience of
uncomfortable closeness I want to be in
everyone's personal bubble is yeah I
don't need I don't need any of that in
my life I'm actually okay that thing's
personal bubble whatever was in there
I'm gonna do without alright fine I'm
gonna do with hey how you doing hey
where did you come from oh they're good
okay well whatever was in there I'm sure
I don't actually need it and my bling
Commodores gone oh it's amazing how that
condition just clears right up whoo
bling Commodore engaged okay I don't
care what's in there huh it got me so
fast before its guy here we go here we
go yeah with Stan's fancy pants who
should I'm not moving
cool good great that's good I'm so happy
about that I'm so glad that that is the
way things that hey listen I don't know
how close I am I don't know how big my
pores seem to you right now but listen I
love you okay
you still there buddy booth you still
there butter but it's that weird sound
but I don't know what that do or I might
take you join cos I don't know what you
did but I you Inc yeah hello Oh Coco
Cola se wait I'm sorry I'm sorry you run
that by me I have a funny feeling this
gonna kill me
here we go Oh refreshing delicious what
did it do I have no idea am I going to
die I know those things are bad for me
bonbon
forget wait oh I've got I still got it
you feel like drinking more would be a
bad idea okay you drank SCP 207 too many
times that was it okay so this is the
closet of food that you don't want to
eat too much of I know that I know how
that works but me I am always ate too
much of that everybody get ready for a
really uncomfortably close reading of
SCP 207 SCP 207 is to be stored in a
waterproof blocking metal container
measuring 1 by 0.5 by 0.5 meters mass
spectrometer and chemical tests have
shown higher than usual concentrations
of caffeine and sugars both natural and
artificial along with redacted the
practical effects of this is when a
subject drinks SCP 207 they will
effectively no longer require sleep or
rest nor attempt to sleep or rest no
subjects have lasted longer than 48
hours during testing which the cause of
death varying from massive internal
organ failure to exsanguinations due to
major artery ruptures tests SCP tools of
an alpha and Rho have shown that after
approximately 24 hours the increases
caused by a CB 207 - 1 means subjects
can easily underestimate their speed
more specifically in SCP u 207 ro
the subject was able to escape the
containment area despite a five meter
wall
however this caused the test subjects
internal bone structure data expunged
why wouldn't you just say that it caused
it to explode out his ass okay so it's a
it's bottle so D that'll kill you dead
if you'll make your brains explode it'll
make your bones melt out through your
eyes real cool huh family L Tommy Ayotte
what I needed in here if I needed
anything at all except the barn barns
why why would I why would I'm in the
Mitsu why I need a bon bon
I need a bon bon I need about I need
whoa whoa Nelly I need some I need some
soda pop is what I need oh yeah it's I
can't run why can't I run I'm trying to
run where where where where okay we're
gonna okay this is great
ooh you're a lot faster what what no
okay good good yeah oh it's so sluggish
on the slop why do you have to slop all
over the this bad you really need to
stop beefing me with those big media
arms of yours you're real hard to run
away from Wow you suck you suck so much
dong oh okay here we go
you're you're a lot worse you're a lot
worse what happened to you used to be
friendly old old uncle Larry Oh Nellie
please stop please stop I wanna get off
radical Larry's Wild Ride okay gets were
off wow he's a lot worse I I can say
that with complete 100% assurance did I
get anything bandaged perfect perfect
all right emptied great exactly what I
wanted man it sure is more difficult
when anything could happen at any time
okay
all right yeah I know how scp-914 gas
experiment well yeah this is just
talking about gas I guess I really
instructions but I get it I get it one
two oh wait no I get it this is trying
to explain how it works but in a
scientific way that's really interesting
refill empty h2o cancer so force at some
point I'm gonna need helium or neon or
argon at some point oh there we go
I'm gonna get some argon or something or
I'm gonna get some helium let's drop
this bad boy drop that oh-ho all right
so one two one two get helium okay
cocoon
nice nice nice yeah that's what I'm
talkin about baby
all right so helium plus oxygen on fine
equals neon because what it's doing is
it's combining the atomic number
fascinating all right let's let's make
some magic
interesting so fascinating I love it
I love it oh whoops wait a minute
medium scrap wait why did I get scrap
but I did it on fine that's what it said
yeah
it is hot in here I'm about to start
sweating bullets all right okay got this
this and this hydrogen oxygen is now oh
no helium that I'm an idiot I'm an idiot
I am an idiot okay hydrogen plus
hydrogen equals helium I didn't even
recognize that other step there that's
very dumb for me so honestly this is an
alchemy machine as it stands right now
which is real cool I love this though
this is like there's never been like a
logical use for this machine and I
haven't thought of it in this way at all
but like it's it's super cool it's it's
super cool it's super cool
I get why neon argon is one to one
because it's it's another noble gas it
doesn't make a lot of logical sense but
whatever okay so if I take one neon and
I put it 1 2 1 it should flip floppy
flip over to argon and I don't know why
I want argon but I
oh yeah
no bells wrong okay Asura wrong about
that one let me just load up again I
love the concept of SCP I really do I
love the concept of essence let me let
me stand back a little bit I love the
concept diversity the idea behind it is
so fun there's so many good SCP stories
out there I feel like someone should
make an SCP movie and do it well do it
with some justice there is so much
potential there's so much potential to
be had out of this universe that has
been collectively made over time it's
just it's just such a fascinating
concept I think everybody loves it like
there's I have yet to meet someone that
is like dude stupid I don't know there's
probably been someone like that re the
way I got to make another one of these I
don't know our gonna get are gone yeah
I'm gonna get our girl I thought you
know for I thought it didn't make sense
cuz that doesn't make any sense with the
whole like it'll become another noble
gas because that it wouldn't make sense
for this to logically work that way so
if it doesn't work that way which I'm
thinking that it doesn't then you know
mm technically I could make anything
with this with enough helium you can
make or it with enough hydrogen you can
make whatever you want that's how stars
did it
that's how stars did it they exploded
everything into everything that we
needed and so we have everything that we
wanted I thought it happened as how was
so he's headed back in the old days the
old days meaning before with was earth
or the planet was a Stardust we're all
made of Stardust what I'm saying we're
all Stardust people's star Dusty's I'm
like getting delirious from overheating
this is like done this is a let's play
of problems right here I got a lot of
issues I got a lot of issues but that's
okay because you guys are here with me
suffering the entire time
suffering through all of this alright so
if I put these bad boys in here then I
should get our gone let me look up a
periodic table period table that's what
I want
neon argon yeah
it's wait there's more I need neon an
oxygen to make argon you can't pull the
fast one on me I'm too smart for you you
think is my first rodeo I'm just gonna
go ahead and get more technically the
elements of the actual canister is iron
so there's some funkalicious feeling
going on here but if I'm right it's this
plus the neon and that's what's gonna do
me that's gonna do me good that on fine
oh baby oh baby oh baby I'm gonna get
some argon oh I'm right and you suck I'm
a toasty biscuit I know I'm a little
grumpy lucious and you have disrespected
me hey I need to get back to a point
where you [ __ ] oh whatever I'll play
your little game here we go we're
playing a game haha fun game hey wacky
game doesn't make any sense unknown
canister anyway I'm gonna stop making
fun of them and I'm gonna get back into
the game ah this looks peaceful I bet
it's not alright anything useful here
okay observation room okay papers
okay big up uh P platform I think they
call us the up B platform that's what I
think they call it up very fine h2 some
type of explosive liquid AG gas with
very loud density do not inhale gas with
very loud density low density oh okay I
see I see that's interesting though I
like that because it's like this weird
scientific approach to something what
did I just pick up helium area really
touch duck what what what what what did
they put me in this game without my
permission
[Laughter]
[Music]
I know that music I know that music I
haven't heard whispered whispers and
ages the documents duck applier of
course it is the object appears to be a
duck sporting features from mark Edward
Fishbach known online as markiplier
subjects in close proximity to the duck
Express a strong boost in charisma
effect seems to only apply regardless of
the emotional state of this subject
that's how it works around me you get
near me listen that's why I'm this close
to you today it's all for a purpose
I'm here to boost your charisma just
looking at a video of mine is like
drinking that Coco Cola you get a plus
boost to charisma and other stats that
will eventually lead to your untimely
explosive demise so don't overdose on me
it'll end badly for the both of us well
thank you for that thank you very much
thank you sorry for playing such a buggy
version of the game this game is really
well made and I like it a lot but now I
realize that I've reached a dead end
and I have to go running back through
the ways of radical Larry doth chased me
and man he doth chase hard but also what
I learned is I don't necessarily need to
run the entire way away from him
my panicking much like everything else
the Frick look out of the corner of my
eye I could see my face over there
that's nice anyway probably nothing
where did that come from
why okay alright nice and not panicking
nice not easy going easy this is the way
I came from not Oh
yeah you know what actually you're fine
oh yeah I wanted to go this way anyway
so I'm gonna go this way yeah yeah uh oh
wait a minute some Akira corporation
chambers running out of argon talked to
scp-914 guys they were working on
something for this you're talking Akira
like the movie Akira while we understand
that some personnel may become
emotionally attached to the SCP items
they're tasked with securing we informed
that public displays of such attachment
are highly unprofessional and may be
damaging to morale and are therefore
discouraged any personnel witnessing
placing memorials writing letters
creating graffiti or other such displays
while inside foundation own property is
subject to reprimand and disciplinary
action up to and including demotion
personnel are encouraged to not interact
with any such display and if located
report them to site administration
immediately if you find yourself growing
attached to an SCP object please report
to your supervisor for psychological
evaluation and counseling interesting
well I have argon Oh what would it do oh
[Music]
okay
I don't know this Zargon
did I not get our gun I thought I got
argon maybe I didn't
maybe I didn't get our gone maybe this
really is an unknown canister and I
meant to get argon which would be
problematic because I over wrote that
save anyway I'll come back to that
unless I just released the evil
I might have released the evil but now
it makes sense
falls under the purview of containment
hello
bathroom bot ghost butt ghost butt ghost
butt ghost butt ghost
you're gonna eat my butt damn it I feel
like the butt ghost is a forgotten thing
from the yonder year of 2013 there used
to be a butt ghost ghost would threaten
to eat your butt it's very scary very
scary was a scare Oso trust me it was so
scary
mmm patreon offices documents phone oh I
know it that there's nothing up there
maybe there's something out there maybe
there wouldn't be anything up here would
that be they make offices for patreon
patreon errs for patronesses okay blood
anyway it's getting a little toasty in
here sama mosey on around no time to
waste
gotta keep moving forward I see oh is it
because I did fine and not one-to-one
Dowd makes sense see it did make sense
but it's not stupid it's it's it's a
little stupid but it's not stupid
there's this one hello ICP $14.99 no was
that warehouse has keycard someone tell
Anderson to speak with them about it oh
is that the gas mask ah that is the gas
mask okay and they really did up they
did an overhaul on this they did an
overhaul Oh speak up
I'm gonna overhaul my ass out of here oh
that's a precarious Oh my grundle why do
you have to slap my ass with such force
radical Larry sorry I gotta get clean
okay so the only thing that I know how
to do now is getting this argon getting
this lusty argonian maid that's what I'm
talking about that's not what I'm
talking about I sometimes my brain just
like connects dots and and it shouldn't
connect them as there's the thing it
should not connect them and it does
anyway I got I should get going
I've looked at the time I got a kit gone
I gotta get argon I gotta get our go
naeun I drink it's thirsty I'll be back
when this is done all right
Neon Neon so one to one is the trick for
this one
I saved did I save I think I saved I I
saved I saved all right give me the
argon I don't know why that happens but
that happens okay cool good great let's
go all right let's save and let's put
some argon into an Akira containment
place and it's gonna do for me but I've
got a good feeling it might be a
possibility when I'm playing this
particular game wink all right cool good
great all right let's to purge it what I
do
[Music]
what am i doing Oh unlock here be
dragons
Odin Oh
[Music]
oh look at him go
whoa what the hell
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know oh yeah I don't know what
the hell that was about but thou so cool
it does remind me that sometimes the
paranormal and the surreal you know it
doesn't always have to be something
horrifying it can be something beautiful
and amazing and wondrous it just doesn't
belong
it's just anomalous I don't know why I
did that but I love doing that I was
great all right cool I'm gonna okay so
this has been a pretty good foray into
the new stuff so far just early early
new stuff in this version of the game
I'm gonna fix my camera and then I'm
going to revisit this properly in a
nearby future episode but they've done a
lot to polish this and I can tell the
work is definitely there so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know if you want more of this down in
the comments below and as always I will
see you
[Music]